well that's the real concern that the
the people that are that have this
dystopian view of artificial
intelligence have is that AI may already
exist that's just sitting there waiting
til Americans many bad movies in in Asia
in Asia everyone thinks AI will be our
friend and will love us in the illest
yeah very very very much that's what you
pump it out there no that's business
their philosophies their I guess I mean
you look in Japanese anime I mean
there's been a eyes and robots for a
long time there there are usually
people's friends there's this dystopian
aesthetic and it's the same in China in
Korea the general guests there is it a
eyes and robots will be people's friends
and will will help people and somehow
the general guests in America is it's
going to be some big nasty Robo soldier
marching down the street we have guys
like Yan musk who we rely upon smarter
than us and he's [ __ ] terrified of it
sam harris terrified of it there are
very smart people that just think it
could really be a huge disaster for the
human race is not just bad because no
it's it's a cultural thing because the
oriental culture is sort of social good
oriented most Orientals think a lot in
terms of what's good for the family or
the society as opposed to themselves
personally and so they just make the
default assumption that guys are going
to be the same way worse americans are
more like mimimi oriented and i say that
as an American as well and that's when
they sort of assumed that a eyes are
gonna be that that's possible it's like
a bro it's like a Rorschach blot right
well whatever is in your mind you impose
on this AI when we don't actually know
what it's gonna become right but there
it is there are potential negative
aspects of course artificial
intelligence deciding that we're
illogical and unnecessary well we are
allowed to go and unnecessary yes but
that doesn't mean that I should be badly
disposed toward this
yeah did you see ex machina I did it
sure it was a copy of our robot so it
was I mean our robot Sophia looks
exactly like the robot in the next
American so it's a good video that
online yeah yeah yeah it would tell
Jamie how to get the good video
oh just search for Sophia Hansen robot
on Google how advanced is Sophia right
now only how many different iterations
have there been there's been something
like 16 Sophia robots made so far we're
moving towards scalable manufacturer
over the next couple years so right
right now she's going around sort of as
an ambassador for humanoid robot kind
giving giving speeches and talks in
various places so she Sophia used to be
called Eva or we had a robot like the
current Sophia that was called Eva and
then X machine that came out with a
robot called Ava that exactly like the
robot that that my colleague David
Hanson and I made I think it's
coincidence
of course not they just copied it and I
mean of course the body they have is
better and the AI is better in the movie
and our robot AI currently is so we
change the name to Sophia which means
wisdom and instead but I mean was it
freaky watching that though with the
name Ava the moral of that movie is just
if you know if a sociopath raises a
robot with an abusive interaction and
may come out to be a sociopath or a
psychopath so let's let's let's not do
that right let's raise our robots with
lovin that's offering compassion yeah
you see the thing is that if we the
familiar this I haven't seen this much
is it actually interacting with them it
really has a nice ring
now I have to make clear that I do